it's monday november 30th
deep deep deep from the heart of jersey
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
it's over thanksgiving's over gobble
gobble
it's a whole new [__] season this is
working with no dough
we keep it low and we make a little
money
with some [__] draftkings how
it's been a rough year
but the game ain't over yet it ain't
over to the fat lady sings
tonight we got a tremendous game we got
seattle
minus five and a half against the
philadelphia eagles
over and under 49 and you start there
you're gonna win tonight and roll into
tomorrow night
baltimore pittsburgh kick off 8 20
eastern
right now both of them was laying seven
and a half
while everybody else is sleeping off
their [__] turkey hangover
and getting trampled like a schmuck
whatever the [__] happened last week
this week
you're gonna get a chance to double your
money when either team scores a
touchdown
you think i'm [__] with you you heard
me right one single touchdown
boom you made it this is what you've
been [__] waiting for
all you got to do is sign up for the
promotion at draftkings
and use promo code joey and wait for the
ball
to cross the [__] end zone that's it
on top of that draftking sportsbook is
giving all new users a chance to earn
a sign up bonus up to a thousand dollars
listen to me download right now today
you're gonna make some money tonight on
a monday
you want to start the week off right
right now download the top-rated
draftking sports app
now and use promo code joey j-o-e-y
when you sign up either to get the
either miss bonus offer double your
money
if either pittsburgh or baltimore score
touchdown
in tuesday night's game that's right it
takes one touchdown
and you double your money when you use
promo code joey
during sign up for a limited time only
only at draftkings sportsbook
it's that easy tonight you when you win
a little money you got seattle but
remember the over and under is 49.
so you got a little angle to make some
little guidance tonight then you come
back tomorrow night
tuesday december 1st you start off the
month
and they're sucking your dick you
understand me you could
bet on the [__] touchdown one single
touchdown
draftkings use code joey it's that easy
and here's the lawyers that is what the
lawyers make me say you ready
you got to be 21 or older you little
young [__] sucker get out of here
go play [__] tiddly winks new jersey
indiana or pennsylvania only
deposit bonus requires a 25 times play
through
what you're gonna do anyway it's only
[__] december 1st
we got college basketball we got pro
[__] football
we got college football we got
everything coming we got [__] bowl
games
we got everything so sit tight this is a
money making month
go to draftkings right now download the
top rated sports app
and use promo code joey all right like i
was saying
you got to be 21 or older deposit bonus
requires a 25 time playthrough
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details
and if you got a gaming problem call
1-800
gambler and if you're in indiana call
1-809
with it but if you don't have a
[__] problem and you're ready
to start making a little bit of baccala
here's the [__] chance right now
draft king sportsbook
use code joey and let's pick up some
[__]
[__] adidas uncle joey's joint is
also brought to you by
the goods cbd lion whether it's the milk
chocolate that comes in dark
and milk chocolate the vapor pens the
roll-on
the kinesiology tape the [__]
tincture
listen whatever you want however you
want a cbd to work it'll work for you
let me tell you a little story for
months i've been rubbing
the cream on my knees and on my legs
after the shower for moisturizing
purposes whatnot
it's been working great i feel great you
know what i went away from the tincture
for a while
and i started using the tincture again
maybe
five nights ago i gotta tell you
something the pain in my legs
and got away 50 percent i took the
weekend off from working out just to get
really give it a really good recovery
but i gotta tell you something way
before that the cbd lion got in there so
i'm gonna tell you from a personal
[__] viewpoint
cbd lion is the way to go go to
cbdlion.com
read all about cbd cbn the benefits
and what it could do for you and start
from there go to cbd line pick what
works for you
whether it's the back ball the
kinesiology tape
the vapor the tincture the gummy bears
which are delicious raspberry tropical
orange strawberry start there you like
something you pick it
you put code in church or joey i get you
off delivered to your house i'm the best
cbd out there in the market today okay
it's that plain and simple no [__]
around
no excuses you got pains you got
anxieties
there's no cure-alls here what i'm
telling you is i'm gonna help you
moderate your pain
moderate your anxiety get you better
sleep make you feeling better about
yourself
that's what cbd lion does all right and
with that
let's get this [__] party
started
look who it is what's happening
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
monday morning
slinging dick feeling good it's the last
day
of [__] november this month is pulled
in may
for uk you're [__] still on lockdown
you're on hitler's status what are you
gonna do
it's [__] monday it's a whole new
week and you gotta [__] pull
or you gotta push [__] forward i had
a great thanksgiving it's crazy
this was my first thanksgiving uh
back in jersey since uh it had to be 84.
yeah 80 [__] four i haven't had a
thanksgiving
here so that stir for 36 [__] years
and it was tremendous i had a great time
listen
and in california it was great the
weather was great all that thanksgiving
day would probably be
90 degrees we would be jumping down but
there was nobody there didn't feel it
never
you never felt the holidays in
california
it was a holiday and you gave your
significant other a kiss and
you had people over but it was really
tough to
feel the holiday if you don't see the
[__] seasons change
like i never even thought about it you
know a guy like me don't give a [__]
about leaves i hate [__] leaves
[__] three weeks we had to break
leaves i couldn't i did it one [__]
day
and then i told my wife just borrow the
[__] blower and we'll blow the leaves
i hate [__] all that [__] with leaves
the only time i blew leaves is as a kid
you blow him into the street
and you make little [__] piles and
you put bricks under there tremendous
and when the car comes down
boom he hits the bricks and we would set
you up
we put them every 40 [__] feet so you
thought you had to beat
and sometimes we let you for the first
one would be free like you'd be
expecting to hit a wall
and it was just leaves and you go woof
and you'd step on it
and then we'd bombard you with the
second wall with the leaves come on
we need to get dealing with some [__]
novice but
uh once you see all that stuff the
leaves changing
you just see the process of it it just
felt like it
uh i had a great day i started out i
went to see my one brother
whose wife died i went down to tom's
river it was [__] 70 degrees
and my line mikey was [__] 70 degrees
at lunchtime when i got down there
i brought like this [__] hooded
sweatshirt take it off
we're sitting outside i saw god this all
the lady who raised me
uh for a few years i got to saw my
brother mike
the brothers the sister you know we sat
around for about an
hour but i wasn't eating there we were
just going to meet there as little up
say hello to each other 11 30. we sat
there from about 11 30
till about 1 15 just saying war stories
my brother looks great god bless him
and then i got in the car and i went to
jackson where my other brother was
and that's where my wife and daughter
were
and uh we just it was just a [__] uh
great time man no buddy talking about
instagram
nobody talking about [__] auditions
nobody talking about what you said on
twitter
nobody nobody even mentioned the [__]
movie
nothing it was just regular just talking
that was it my daughter got bombarded
playing with dogs one of the dogs
knocked her over
everywhere she went she got a little
[__] toy and then we were headed home
i was just telling mike
the last three nights we've been out to
like 10 o'clock at night it's been like
a [__] different life for us here
uh that was thursday on the way home the
florentines are like well we're here
waiting at 7
30. we went over there there was still
[__] a party going on over there
so it was still nice out that night it
was still cool we just played outside
the kids played some ball a little bit
we just the parents talked some [__]
outside
some of his brothers was there and i
came home me and my wife looked at each
other
like that was [__] great that was
[__] great
you know friday i had to take my
daughter to a kickboxing camp from ten
to three
she was in kickboxing which freed me and
my wife up
we did a little lunch because it was our
anniversary wednesday we
couldn't go anywhere so we took a little
[__] lunch
pool you know we drove around we got to
hang out so that was nice
three o'clock my [__] daughter my
wife tells me she's at 12. she's like oh
by the way
i hope you're on your own for dinner
tonight because we're going out
some girl around the corner invited us
over for christine for thanksgiving for
kids
so we're going to be there till [__]
8 o'clock at night i was like jesus
christ
these guys are doing more than we did
but they're doing more now
than we've ever done in our [__]
lives saturday and sunday were [__]
uh you know off the [__] charts to
saturday she had to go to kickboxing
from kickboxing i took it to the [__]
park from the [__] park we went
somewhere else
from there we met some friends and went
to [__]
eat and then from there we went over to
jimmy florentine's brother to watch liv
uh jimmy florentine's live show last
night i'm happy that you guys uh
download it i i tweeted up the link for
you
we went over there saturday night and
watched that till [__] 10 o'clock
and then sunday we went to [__] uh
great adventure to the [__] outdoor
with the animals and [__] like that
it's a scary situation it just never
stops but this is how a family lives
you know usually i'd be getting home on
a [__] sunday i had missed all of
thanksgiving
last year on this weekend i was in
[__] miami
and this week coming up it was my it was
a year ago this friday
when all of you [__] bad new
yorkers
new jerseys and you brooklyn [__]
converted
on town hall and we sold out two [__]
shows
what a difference a [__] year makes
what a [__] difference
a year makes last week we were all
getting ready for friday night at town
hall
saturday night at the [__] wilbur we
were getting [__] ready now
i'm getting ready for dick this week i'm
getting ready for the maybe the release
of some new [__] christmas movie or
some [__]
which the movies are closed but listen
guys we got our [__] health
we got each other you know a lot of
people are getting covered so please
be careful take care of yourself you
know hey listen
everything is a covarial situation
anymore
because you don't know where the [__]
you're gonna get it but if you leave the
house put your [__] mask on
i don't give a [__] i was listening to
ozzy's bone yet oh by the way
thank you for all the support on
aussie's boneyard i
have blew myself away with the songs i
picked
i must hate eight quaaludes that night
because i was [__] brain dead during
the day i just didn't know how to act
this was my first time ever on aussie's
boneyard and i didn't know how to [__]
the act i didn't know if i'd go wild i
didn't know if i could talk about eating
[__]
i didn't know what i could talk about so
i tried to keep it
uh as mild as i could and i gave you the
best songs i could i couldn't believe
they kept rotten apple
by [__] allison chains you know i
pushed
i pushed about listen i listened to
ozzy's bone y'all a lot
you know i listened to ozzy's barnyard
lithium
i mean i'm a [__] serious like xm guy
studio 54 octane i listen to [__]
everything
and i wanted to play songs i had never
really heard on that before
you know i've heard souls stripped
around there before i haven't heard
animal magnetism on there before
i haven't heard a lot of this [__] that
i played on there before so
listen a little [__] tap on my back
for once
because i think i did okay let me get
the [__] one of these flies off my
shoulder here
i still got one i found all these flies
the other day
uh in the box he just flew out of the
[__] box
but i love you [__] guys for
supporting me and tonight
is the last play at 6 00 p.m eastern
so if you want to give me one more
little piece of support
ozzie's bony on at 6 p.m eastern you
know what
i don't even know they told me that the
other night they told me they were
playing at one in the morning saturday
sunday morning i got in the car to take
a ride and they write
my voices on i'm like what the [__] am i
doing on here sunday morning so
i never know when the [__] time enjoy
it if you hear it thank you for
listening to the whole thing through
don't just hear three [__] songs and
throw my algorithms off [__]
once you put it on sit there at the
escrow's roots
and hear it all the way to the end don't
[__] embarrass me
but even i was listening to the uh
ozzie's boneyard had an interview this
week with
uh billy sharon i think that's his name
he interviews ozzy osbourne they do some
pretty [__] great stuff and they were
talking about california and the fires
and
you know uh who the [__] knows i forget
what i was gonna tell you now
but i just wanted to thank you for
supporting me
on ozzie's boneyard and it was funny
there was an event this that happened
this weekend that really made me think
about
just my life and what made me turn out
how i did
i don't know if i i told you
[__] i got a thousand stories
the only problem is two thousand i can't
tell this one i could tell
you know way a lot of people who see me
now
that are a little older than me always
go to me wow you know it's
it's great to see you you know it's
great to see you become a man
he goes all i remember is you with that
[__] jew fro
bouncing that [__] ball that's what
people always say to me bouncing that
[__] ball
bouncing that [__] ball doug i love
basketball
you know but i want to get a story out
that a lot of people don't know and i
don't want to
i hate when people blame marijuana for
everything
i lost my car keys and then some
jerk-off will say
stop smoking pot it's ruining your brain
shut the [__] up
it's always marijuana don't blame
marijuana around me it's not the reason
why
uh
a lot of people get confused about me
they think that
after my mother died is when i went off
the deep end a little bit
and i got to tell you something guys i
disagree with that
i was going off the deep end a little
before my mother died
and there was just a series of events
that
i didn't know how to handle as a young
man that happened to him tell me
no no boy scouts raped me and nothing
like that i was very fortunate i'm just
talking about
life has a weird way of [__] uh
you know i'm just showing up on you you
i my struggle in my life listen the
first
the church of what's happening now was
about me telling lee my stories
to if you look at it in a [__] micro
way
it was me telling mila my stories as a
young man
so he could grow up into something
better that's what
the church was about okay with uncle
joey's joint without a guest
it's basically about the actions i did
why i didn't
you know let's go and check on these
things
because i'm just once i came back to
jersey i
changed you know we all change every
seven years we've talked about that but
i got to be honest with you
we've changed during this [__]
pandemic
we've changed our views on a couple
things we got to see things we did we
hadn't seen in a long time
we got to visit things on our mind we
didn't get to visit a few times you know
i was talking to josh wolfe the other
day and we're talking about the material
and he asked me what i was going to do
with my material for march
was i still doing it and i told him i
was still doing it
but it's not who the [__] i am anymore
he was talking about a particular bit i
was doing and i'm like
i i've been running the bit lately at
uncle vinnie's but
it's not who i am anymore i gotta start
from scratch again
like whether the [__] we were in march
we're just not the same [__] person
no more
i don't give a [__] what you think
somewhere along the line
we got jaded a thing called jaden
okay that's when something happens and
we lose a little trust
towards things for some people with
stress towards their employers
for some people it was trust towards the
system for every
everybody lost something during this
pandemic here
and we feel a little jaded like
somewhere along the line
somebody could have done a little better
but you know you can't sit there all
your life point your fingers at [__]
people
sometimes we have to accept what we do
and what happens around us
and how we respond and how we [__]
react
so when i was a kid i got thrown out of
that catholic school
my mother sat me down and she told me we
had two situations on the table
we could do it her way or we could do it
my way
if we did it my way first
it was fine but the first time i slipped
i was done
i was have to do it back to her way and
that was military tactics
that was uh you know getting searched
and thousands of other [__]
rules that would have been put in place
i decided to play it my own way
the first thing life did to me once i
got out of catholic school
well what what life does to everybody
you know everybody gets their first
[__] ass kicking and
it's called from a thing called love we
all get beat up by love
each one of you people that have watched
this whether you're male
or female encounter love at some young
age
and you get the [__] not daddy it
doesn't work out well for you at one
point or another
you know i know 90 of the people
watching this [__] podcast
and somewhere along the line had a
you know a year off because that's
something for
the first heartbreak we've ever had you
know maybe we were cheated on
maybe we were lied to you know we all
watched these [__] romantic comedies
and think we're gonna show up just like
that splash a chick's gonna show up by
the ocean and be a mermaid and
i'm gonna fall in love with her for the
rest of my life little does she tell you
that she's got a brother who's a junkie
a [__] she used to be a hooker but a
[__] fellow you know
they got a thousand stories but but
that's that that's not the point here
the point
is here that when i was like in the
sixth grade i i
fell in love with this [__] girl and
uh
you know towards the end of the sixth
grade
uh when i first went to mckinley my
first year i felt very insecure
you know the only thing that had me a
little secure there was
some cuban kids in the class you know so
i felt a little bit more secure
mckinley but my insecurity [__]
levels were completely off
i was a martial artist at the time at
that age
and the whole thing but when i went into
the sixth grade i just
my insecurity levels were an all-time
low
and then that summer i started hanging
out with these guys and
you know we were robbing trains and
whatever and i
still didn't have an identity but from
things that i
did it gave me an identity i had to be
the craziest one out of the crew
to obtain any type of identity so he
started calling me crazy coco
whatever the [__] they were calling me
you know and i ended up falling in love
with this little young girl you know
when you're a kid
you fall in love with girls and
uh at the time i wasn't
uh as popular as the other kids or
whatever so the girl pulled me aside
and she told me that uh she couldn't
date me during the school year
that she would have to wait till the
summer that's how stupid i was that's
that's
that's just uh that's what a girl tells
you when you're [__] the sixth grade
that same girl is the girl at the strip
club that tells you to meet her at
denny's after the ship's over
and you go to denny's with your three
[__] buddies and wait for her she
never shows up
well that's the same thing that happened
to me at the end of the [__] uh
seventh grade she told me that she
didn't want to [__] uh be my
girlfriend she wasn't ready for it yet
and i'll first of all just falling in
love with the girl
my schoolwork went from a's all the way
down to d
i mean i couldn't focus on anything else
but this girl i couldn't wait to be
around her
you know we don't know we don't know
anything about love so we
we we act out what we see in movies i
always showed up with flowers
to a house i had to take a grandma to
the movie theaters when i was a [__]
kid
[__] that [__] today i would have never
taken nobody's grandma to the movie
theaters and sat there
with the grandmother in between i had to
do the whole [__] thing deal
guys and then she tells me she doesn't
want to be my [__] girlfriend
and then that summer [__]
school i did so bad with my grades the
whole [__] year i had to go to summer
school
but she drove me crazy and we went
here's the funny thing guys
i got no reason a lot of you guys there
was no sex involved
if she would have gave me a taste of her
[__] my head would have probably blown
up i would have moved out of the [__]
house
this was just sucking tits and dry
humping that's how weak of a [__] kid
i was she
this was just love i was just in love
with her
and the [__] uh you know sixth grade
going into seventh grade came i thought
we were gonna go into the eighth grade
together
but i got left back you know how bad you
feel when you're insecure
you're [__] spanish you got like
eight strikes again
and now you get left back it was the
[__] most humiliating
thing in my life but you know what the
most humiliating thing about it
it wasn't getting left back it wasn't
her breaking my heart
it was that i was smart
there was no reason for me to get left
back i was a smart
[__] kid just off the cuff somewhere
how can i get left [__] back it was
[__] infuriating for me
it was infuriating for me thank god
they put me in a guy's classroom that
his name was john varun
the only thing i had to get me out of
that left back hole
and that broken heart the only
three things i had were music
karate and a thing called basketball
i [__] went to karate
i listened to them some of the music
that you guys are getting on the music
review right now the album of the week
and i played basketball like it was
commitment i got
that girl out of my [__] head one way
or another
and i committed my life to [__]
basketball
if there was a drill you could do to get
better i did it
if there was a book you could buy i
[__] did it
i got a list of all the acc colleges all
my favorite coaches
at the time the coach of north carolina
dean smith and
the guy from [__] duke and the guy
from georgia tech
and i wrote the more handwritten letters
and told them to send me their [__]
workouts of what their kids were doing
in college
and i stuck to that workout i had heard
a rumor that jerry west
before the day even started shot 300
[__] free throws a day
just to get the day started and that's
what i started doing
winter spring summer a [__] fall
if it snowed out me and my gorilla
buddies would go there with a [__]
ice pick
and a shovel and we'd shovel the courts
put [__] on our own pockets by ice
that [__] [__] that they put on the
[__] ice
and we'd melt the ice and we'd play
basketball with a [__] basketball
that the oxygen was frozen in
the ball wouldn't even bounce that's how
much i loved [__] basketball i did
everything i could
and then guess what happened in the
seventh grade i had more [__]
heartache
we went 0-7 we were the [__]
doormat of the [__] league me a kid
named chucky mcbreen that's a head coach
of ramapo state college
i just spoke to him thursday he's one of
my brothers in life
we're brothers to the end his brother
bruce
uh you know we played back i mean they
taught me everything chuck mcbreen
schooled me you know he had gone to
booze basketball camp
so he talked me into going to willis
reed basketball camp
i went to booze basketball camp with my
man ralph a fuso we still talk on the
phone too
40 [__] 50 years later
i did everything i could i went into
that eighth grade and our [__] goal
was to be at least
five and [__] there was seven games so
we could be
[__] seven games so if we could be
[__] four and three
i would be [__] ecstatic at least we
paid i played above 500 ball
but that we couldn't find the [__]
coach and a coach wouldn't [__] coach
us
so i turned to mr barrow now the reason
why mr brown is so significant
in this story is because baron and i
didn't like each other
when i was in mr kingwell's class to the
point where the first day of seventh
grade they put me in his classroom
because they they said you know if
you're definitely going to eighth grade
you sit upstairs with an eighth grade
classroom but if you're gonna go into a
if you're going to summer school you're
definitely not going to the eighth grade
so you have to sit in the other seventh
grade class where you're going to be in
next year
dog for those four hours he tormented me
he goes how's it gonna
feel sitting next to me every [__]
day i'm gonna [__] torture you
you blew it over a girl i was living so
when i got up to leave i saw his car
keys were on the desk
with his house keys and a bunch of other
keys i took the [__] car keys and i
threw him away in the [__] garbage
out the dumpster and [__] two hours
later i'm on my back
i'm on my block hanging out with my
friends and i see his
nissan a toyota car coming up the hill
and he's like where the [__] are the
rest of my keys you [__] scumbag
you're gonna fail we went at it we had
an argument in the middle of the street
but here's where it [__] turns
i go into the seventh grade i i you know
uh
failed out of summer school i failed
out of summer school
so guys listen i was i had bto
on my [__] forehead i was born to
lose and here the whole time this is
going on
my mother doesn't know anything about
this
i'm keeping this as hush hush as you
[__] can at the house okay
nobody knows nothing about nothing so
now i go to summer school i'm over there
heavy with the combined balzano crew
you know his crew has got power up at
the school
you know maybe he could do something for
me i'm [__] around
i'm playing hooky from summer school to
hook up with the girl that broke my
heart how much of an [__] am i
and after four days they came to me and
said listen you had more than three
absences
we got to throw you out of summer school
and i'm like yeah but i got plans i'm
gonna go to the eighth grade
i'm gonna like we don't know what type
of plans you got you didn't go to summer
school
we can't move you forward
i went to carmine i went to other people
that i knew at the end
of the township and they were like uh
you didn't go to summer school
we can't [__] help you so i still
remember
walking into barron's class that day in
the seventh grade and i'm like i'm
walking into a kid's class
a guy's class that [__] hates me for
stealing his
keys i might get left back again
just out of principle i might spend my
whole life in the [__]
seventh grade i went in that man
and the reason why me and mr barone are
still dear friends is
he never said nothing about it
somewhere in his mind we started from
zero
and i didn't know i was a [__] just
dumb kid i didn't know where to go in my
mind
so i just went along with the [__]
flow i didn't say much
i did what i had to do he made a remark
at me from time to time
but it was never the way our
relationship was before
and then to the grace of god something
i found out that [__] here he uh
i i found out that he [__] uh
uh was in the basketball
hall of fame whoa
so i want to be a [__] great
basketball player
but my nemesis the guy i hate
the guy that threw away his keys the guy
that tormented me
is in the basketball hall of [__]
fame
i found this out in conversation so i
said [__] this
so i didn't want to embarrass him at the
school i didn't want to really pull him
over at the school because i didn't
really want anybody to know i like this
[__]
i was still playing it off like i didn't
like this [__]
so i got on a [__] bus
and i shot up to 90th street where he
lived at the time
and i remember walking down the hill and
you know
i took the [__] phone and his address
and this phone number from the yellow
pages
there was no internet you had to go to
yellow pages and hope that person
paid the service because back then
either you paid
not to be in the book or you paid to be
in the yellow book
i don't know don't quote me it doesn't
matter you're like joey what's a yellow
page anyway
doesn't matter doesn't matter there's an
old man talking to you
i actually went to his house like a man
right there 12 years old i knocked on
his door
he answered like you're the last person
that should be on my [__] doorstep
and i was like mr barone i want you to
teach me about basketball because he had
a basketball right in front of his house
and he [__] looked at me like
kid you got some [__] pair of balls
and he goes let me go upstairs and put
on my sneakers his
his younger brother had been on north
bergen state championship team
so he came downstairs and right away we
just went over fundamentals we went over
a bunch of [__]
you know i talked to him a little bit
about college ball i mean i talked to
him a little bit about high school ball
you know i wanted to see what i was
getting myself into but it was just like
stand-up comedy
you know like when i look back at my
basketball career and how i [__] dove
myself in it
it's like stand up i got a job at
cooney's a club called woodson
in colorado and i watched and i watched
[__]
uh comedy from february so i finally got
some balls between my legs and went up
on stage on july 19th
so i knocked on this guy's door he
[__] helped me with basketball
and brother that night i went home and i
committed myself to basketball
i did everything i had to do i lifted
[__] weights
i used to sit on the wall like you you
put your back against the wall and just
sit there
to strengthen my legs i would run at
night at mckinley school with a girl
named kathy moran
we're still dear friends we would get
together at night
and just do cross-country [__]
running
and i would play basketball eight to ten
[__] hours a day if in the summers my
days started at eight i would take my
bike
and ride up to the [__] projects and
take 300 jump shots
just like [__] jerry west i mean i
was all
[__] in going into the eighth grade
as a matter of fact the summer of me
going into eighth grade
was 77. i found out about different camp
that was going on in jersey city
called stupid superstar basketball camp
and it was run by bob hurley billy and
danny's [__] father
the guy that [__] brought the hurley
brothers into the [__] world
because he coached saint anthony's a
jersey city
so i went down to his camp and that was
the week that [__] elvis presley died
august of 77 who the [__] do you think
you're dealing with
and i went down to this camp and in my
category
i won outstanding rebounder
listen guys that meant more to me that
had taken me out of the [__]
shallows of the grave i was in between
the catholic school thing
the [__] uh the girl who broke my
heart
getting left back the [__] sunday
school see
listen guys i tell you about all the
good things
i never tell you about the bad things
because i didn't want to be listen
if you want a violin i'll be a violin
i'll sit here hour
after hour every week and just play a
violin for you
of all the bad [__] that happened but i
just talked to you about the good stuff
to happen because we don't
need to know about the bad [__] that
happened but it's time that i came out
with the bad [__] that happened
it was bad it was bad my [__] and
this is way before my mom died
i don't want you guys to see you know i
did a podcast
after that whole thing with that i'm not
going to tell you with who
i did a big time podcast and
with uh with the thing with the
videotape when i said that the 20 chick
sucked my dick
and i meant that the same chick sucked
my dick 20 times the same [__] chick
it wasn't 20 different retards it's who
is something like dick
you have to be [__] [__]
especially at that time in 97
but after i said that
i'm like i don't even know we're talking
about mike that's how [__] on fire i
am
no so i did this [__] podcast
with uh a guy that's a popular guy and
you know he was trying to blame my life
my mom's death
listen if you want me to sit here and
play a violin for you
and tell you the reason why i did coke
the reason why i stole
the reason why i became a criminal and
the reason why i threw somebody in a
trunk of a car
was because of the death of my mother if
you want to buy that
i'll tell you that if that's what you
want to buy that's what you've been
that's the story you've been buying from
every [__] hooker with a [__] has
a heartbreak story
every hooker has a heartbreak story if
you want to buy that story
then i went downhill after my mother
died you buy you buy that story
but that's a complete [__] and i
never sold it that way either
that's a complete [__] story my
decline
was descending before my mother died
and it was because of the story i'm
about to tell you
so everything i did in my life was to be
a better basketball player
on the weekends i smoked a little bit of
pot i was a [__]
top athlete i went to karate every
[__] day
so on top of my basketball on top of the
and i delivered newspapers
and i [__] went to my mother's bar
and had to help i would [__] every day
so my days were filled i would go to
basketball practice
deliver papers walk up the hill to my
mom's bar help her
and then do a 7 30 karate [__] class
i've always been a [__] animal
nothing's ever [__] been handed to me
here
you gotta work you gotta get out and
[__] move
so i went to [__] superstar
basketball camp
i won outstanding rebounder of the
[__] week and you guys could check
this all out with mr hurley
you contact the guy named jim hague that
i was on his podcast he's a
sports writer for the jersey uh from
north bergen jersey city guy great guy
went to saint peter's prep i think
i know all those guys i want the
five-star basketball camp that's
howie garfinkle's camp that's one of the
best camps in the country
i went there with uh philly dickinson
university's coach greg horinda
we go back deep [__] this was a
different joey coco diaz
this is way before stand up this was way
before [__] people got put in the
trunk of a car
this is way before his mom died and he
became a junkie
this was just when i was regular joey
cocod is trying to [__] make it
across
yeah i was embedded in the carmine
balzano house
so the word got out so that helped me a
little bit to get across
but i was earning my stripes on my
[__] own nobody was giving me dick
once i [__] won the outstanding
rebound that hurley's [__] joint
i went into the eighth grade we were
[__] spot
on to win it it was me this kid chucking
mcbreen
this kid dave ruiz i forget who the
center was
and we had a kid that just transferred
in from new york
his name when he was dominican his name
was louis hernandez and like i told you
thousand times no disrespect since he
was the only person with an
afro within a 10 mile radius they just
gave the name louis the [__] that was
it
and no disrespect nothing racist i don't
want [__]
uh uh black lives matter marching on my
house
we're talking about 1978 it was a
different time in this country do you
understand me so relax
get your [__] uh put away your
petitions
so [__] right away let's sign a
petition
joey said the n-word and i didn't mean
it like that i'm just saying
what his nickname was at the time louis
hernandez had legs
that was that was it i forgot the thing
the front row was me
louie and dave that was the two forwards
and the center and the two guards were
chucking mcbreen who today is the coach
head coach around the post state college
and this kid by the name of anthony
bonzano
how's that one for you so it was us
[__] five we're gonna start
and our plan was to take that [__]
league apart ah
but [__] september david ruiz shows
up and tells us that
his father got a job downtown and he's
got a transfer to [__] kennedy school
so that ruined our [__] plans we had
to come up with a new idea
i still remember mr barone calling
bennett mcdonald's right to his face in
the classroom
the two months that he had to sit there
before he moved he would just talk
purposely call him benny benny benny and
david go what did i do
betty don't even say a word benny
benedict arnold benny so
dave is a great kid god bless him i know
he still lives in the area
i haven't spoken too many years so dave
ruiz goes to kennedy school
and now it's me louis hernandez i can't
remember who we use as a center
and uh we had [__] chucky
and anthony [__] bowzano
and we had a great season we had a great
time we ended up going four and three
four and [__] three was a winning
record
and here's what happened first we had a
coach and then he quit peter where quick
because he couldn't pass
the background check i don't even think
they did a background check back then
i think he just raped too many kids and
the word hadn't gotten her out yet i i
don't
i don't [__] know what he did he was
a good guy he was a great guy i
shouldn't even have thrown that rape
joke in
he was a great guy something happened he
just couldn't get it together
and then we had this guy joe the german
who was a racist [__]
and we were we got him fired this
morning story
we'll touch on it later and [__] joe the
german and then he got fired
and then mr barone who wasn't a coach at
the time
he was just a seventh grade teacher we
did a thing where we went outside in
front of the high school
and he was walking out of high school he
just happened to bump into us
while we were out there doing our thing
and we went over some plays
do you know what i mean there was no
basketball
rim around but he just told us plays we
should do
it was plays based on numbers a one to
five series
whatever the [__] it was and we ended up
going four and three
at the same time i played for st
michaels and cyl
for union city that's why i gave a shout
out
to uh whatever when he died tommy
heintzen
a couple weeks ago he had gone to that
seat the reason why i played for
st michael's coil was because of tommy
heinsohn
he led the county in scoring blah blah
blah blah blah
i had options i could play for saint
augustine in union city
or i could have played for our lady of
fatima and north bergen
but i went with st michaels because for
a lot of people know st
michaels was the saint who batted
[__]
whatever the devil whoever converted the
devil
out of [__] hell and in other words
he's [__] all goon
so i ended up going to saint michaels
into the plane
we had a green [__] you know we had
to be like leprechauns or some [__]
i don't know what the [__] we were but
uh it was a great experience throughout
my eighth grade year
and i was being curated i was being
cultured i was gonna be
a [__] uh a great add-on to any of
the schools i went to
whether it was going to be north bergen
or whether it was going to be saint
anthony's
you're looking at a guy that was being
spoken to to go to saint anthony's in
jersey city
one of the top high school basketball
[__] schools in the [__] country
you guys could call dan hurley do
whatever you want
everybody knew this it was me from north
bergen they were looking at me
whitey o'donnell and chucky [__]
mcbreen
they were looking at us three we were
getting invited to different aau games
i played on the saint anthony's aau team
with a guy named mandy johnson
a bunch of us i mean everything was
looking like i was gonna go to saint
mike uh
saint anthony's but i knew if i went to
saint anthony's
i wasn't gonna lie to you i was gonna i
was gonna sit the bench
i was gonna probably be a pretty good
seventh or sixth man
maybe an eighth guy but i wasn't gonna
start they had talent from all over the
[__] state
i decided just to go to northberg and i
go let me
anthony's is great for my resume
but my mother hasn't produced any
pictures of any of my cousins being over
six feet
so before my mother produces one of
those pictures
of one of my cousins that are over six
feet but she kept telling me my dad was
six foot four
so your dad's six foot four before he
died he you
you got a chance at this basketball [__]
but i wanted to see pictures of other
cousins that were over six feet
and she couldn't produce none of them so
i ended up going to mckinley i had a
good height
uh i'm the height i am now as a freshman
five ten and a half i was lanky
but i could do something that a lot of
people couldn't do i could [__]
rebound
i could rebound 38th street basketball
court
was not a 10-foot court it was 9
feet 10 inches it was missing two inches
to be a complete 10-foot court and i was
just
missing slam dunking on it that's how
high of a jumper i was
i had worked on my legs so much i got a
bicycle i would put the
basketball in between the front tire and
that little space
and i would pedal up up my hills 20
times
i would walk around with [__] spats
around my ankles
they're one of the worst things you
could wear those weights you wear around
your ankles
i would run with those things they
separate the front of the [__] knee
from the knee oh that's what they told
us then who gives a [__]
i look like some [__] uh whatever the
[__] some [__] trinity i'm not a
trainer i'm just telling you what they
told me
but i actually did all those things i
worked really
[__] hard now that eighth grade
basketball was [__] done
my eyesight was on freshman year i was
going to north bergen
and i was [__] starting and i was
going to start my four years
and i was going to go to a great college
i had inspirations up the ass i had a
kid named michael corrin out of jersey
city
who started not went not played
not [__] wore t-shirt started for
north carolina
the tar heels started his freshman year
i had to [__] beat that who the [__]
starts
at north carolina their freshman [__]
year
michael jordan that's who starts but
another guy
michael cory michael somebody got hurt
in the middle of the season
or corinth started playing as a freshman
and they [__]
made him play and he [__] started
them and then in the ncaa
finals against unlv he [__] scored
30 points or something like that against
[__]
uh i forgot the guy he tried he was a
great basketball player
he could shoot 40 footers i swear to god
this
guy can make 30 footers with his eyes
shut
but 10 years ago he tried to shoot
himself with a 22.
he put in his heart and he missed what
good are you you know what i'm saying
can you believe that [__] his name was
glenn gonzizek he played for the knicks
he was six foot five white guy tougher
than dead i give him and his whole
family props
they will out of boulder colorado that's
how small that's how small my [__]
circle runs
my jimmy runs he was out of [__]
colorado
uh i [__] you know
respected him whatever but that anyway
michael korin started
so my career already had an outlook
i had a goal i didn't know anything
about goals then i'm not going to tell
you i was writing goals back when i
wasn't right no [__] goals
my goal was to go to high school
start my freshman year
play varsity my sophomore year not start
hopefully start this is very
embarrassing to tell you guys this
but this is my plan start my junior year
start my senior year at bio county and
hopefully end up going to a division one
school
that was my that would have kept my mom
off my tail
that would have kept everybody off my
tail the problem was
i would have started telling my mom my
senior year
my junior year that i wasn't graduating
something must have happened
i would have to come up with a why
because my mother had never known
that i had [__] gotten left back i
didn't have the balls to tell her
it would have broke around the inside my
mother knew i was smarter than that
i knew i was smarter than that but
because i didn't know here the [__]
system
i got [__] left back so everything i
had in me was headed
that was the plan freshman year start
sophomore year start var i'll play
varsity
not start knock on wood if i was that
good i'd love to start my
sophomore year because then you got is
nothing but up
and then junior and senior year all
county all-state
and i could have gotten me myself myself
chucking me breen
why the o'donnell could all gone to
division one schools
that was the [__] plan okay
uh towards the end of my [__]
eighth grade year our dear friend and uh
shooting guard anthony bonzano died
that deflated me a little bit i still
continued to play
i wore uh my [__] wristbands with his
numbers in it whatever number he was
in grammar school i think it was 32.
that [__] beat me to julia
servings number before i could do it
and uh
i [__] my whole 8th grade summer
that's all i did
no girlfriends a little bit of reefer
i uh played basketball every [__] day
and if i went up to union city to my
mom's bar i did whatever the [__] i had
to do up there
but i also went to gilmore and played
basketball in union city
that was the hot basketball court that's
what good basketball players
[__] went at that time i was also
going to hoboken
to 4th street park taking my ass down
there where there was some hooping and
[__]
two guys one guy was going to boston i
did
everything i could to prepare for
freshman year
not to have any problems i didn't want
any [__] problems
i was starting my freshman year with no
[__] hassles
freshman coming to freshman year comes
along school starts
i go up there they're pushing me to play
football
they're like you gotta do something you
gotta do something to go into the
basketball and he goes your best bet is
to play football
because one of the defensive coaches
is the head basketball coach and if
you're going that way
you get to [__] talk to him that way
and now by the time basketball season
comes
he'll know you and you'll be a
basketball player that was an
option for me that was an option for me
but you know what i wasn't a football
player
i was a basketball player i had trained
hard
i had worked hard to be a [__]
basketball player and that's all i
wanted to [__] do
so instead of playing football you ready
for this one
grab your seats [__] sit down i
ran
cross-country track
[Laughter]
they gave me some sneakers some red
[__] sweatsuits
and it made me go to hudson county park
at first they tried to make me a high
hurdler
because i could jump really well but my
speed wasn't any good
i was always quick not fast big
difference
being quick and being fast is two
different [__]
things some people could do a 4.3
[__] 40. i can't
take my two years to do a 40. but can i
get to that location in a certain amount
of time
you bet your ass so
i get the freshman year they want me to
play [__] basketball i tell them to
suck my dick up football
i tell them to suck my dick i'm gonna be
a basketball player
i lifted weights i did everything i
could i
come november 15th i [__] tried out
for basketball
everything i made the team my name was
on the list
i'm looking to [__] start you know
they did a couple weeks i mean
the coach's name was dan ridden and he
was a good basketball coach
um he opened up the year focusing on
defense
for the first two weeks of practice you
did not touch a ball
you did sprints you did [__]
sprints and you did more sprints you did
gorilla drills
that's where you [__] walk around
like a gorilla practice on your defense
and we worked on cutting off [__]
baselines
cutting off passing lines cutting off
running lines cutting off all
routes that's what we focused on uh
to me i could handle it i could do
whatever the [__] he wanted me to do
i was agile i was quick you know i could
shoot i could rebound
i had [__] heart you know or i
thought i had heart
well you know what after the first three
or four weeks
we started putting the [__] teams
together
and i wasn't starting
what are you saying
i was up on the third team of reserves
i wasn't starting i wasn't on the second
team
i was on the third team of reserves
it was mind-boggling
yeah i had been hurt over the left back
yes had been broken divided by the girl
yes you know i had other things that
were
not working out for me as a young
teenager but not
the [__] start when i could wipe my
ass with everybody else on that [__]
court
i mean i was worlds amongst those other
guys on that [__] court
except for chucky whitey mahoney we all
knew together
everybody else i could run with and
[__]
jump higher than i had more balls with
this guy wouldn't say it i thought
he wants me to earn it i got nothing
wrong with earning anything
i'll stick it out two three more weeks
by the time the christmas tournament
starts
i'll be starting there was a christmas
tournament and even playing the [__]
game
i mean there was games where i would
just dress up and not get put in
you have no idea the heartache i had
that
the [__] heartache i was going
through and the [__] embarrassment
was [__] painful jack
people are coming up to me going what
the [__] is going on
why isn't this guy starting you and
and every time somebody would ask me
that it would
[__] bury me into a
a [__] deep a [__] predicament
i ended up you know the school the
basketball season
started in uh you know november of 78
and we were done by probably january of
79.
and i was done i was [__] heartbroken
i didn't know what to say i didn't know
how to face my friends
i didn't know how to face with the
coaches i didn't know how to face myself
you know it affected me so much
that a month after [__] basketball i
quit karate
i quit karate february 19
1979 on my [__] birthday
and i quit karate because
i wanted to do drugs see with the people
the jocks i hung out with we got high
once
maybe twice a week we did a couple of
[__] joints
busted out the visine but then
with karate they were more nerds we
would go to chinatown
we would do [__] like that on the
weekends we never really [__]
uh got high the pain
from that basketball and from that coach
from danny ridden
and from what i had just experienced was
just too much
it was ready to start partying and
shortly after that like this was uh
february of 79 i hit the number on my
birthday
for 5 000 bucks and within two weeks
i got into the drug selling business i
was selling a little weed
a little mexican a little acid by the
summertime i was doing thc
crystal 79 and uh
my mother ended up dying that november
of 79
and i never really got back into
basketball
after that and it's always been a
heartbreak of mine
and this weekend
uh you don't have to went down to my
friend bobby bender's house and uh
her mother you know his mother-in-law
was like all i remember you is
this is a kid with an afro and a [__]
basketball and i was like wow
and then to top it off sunday
yesterday i got a text not a text
message
an email from a friend of mine in
florida that said that he had lost my
number
and he had just gotten an email from a
friend of mine or from a webpage or
something
and that he wanted to re-connect with me
to give him a call i was really excited
i had wondered about this guy had lost
all in
his information we haven't spoken about
seven years
and uh when i called him back he goes
the reason why i was calling you was
he goes i went to a pool thing today
and i bumped into a kid and we started
talking
and the kids sounded like you he goes he
was
from union city or something like that
uh he told me what the kids name you
know the kid's name was rudy or whatever
and he goes uh we didn't talk about he
goes at the kids set
they were talking and he said that he
knew me for the last
couple years since basketball but the
kid rudy said
no i know him since he's a [__] kid
and he goes what a lot of people don't
know about
joey diaz a lot of people
don't know was that he was a really
really really good ball player really
good he could have gone to college
he could have done great but
the power was to be the coaches [__]
them that year
the coaches just didn't that coach you
know
listen between you and i i always knew
that coach [__] me
i always knew he didn't like me i pulled
him over a couple times and tried to
talk to him
and he would always make some snide
remarks
and after my mother died i wanted to
[__]
i wanted to [__] kill him you know i
was like [__] i'm gonna go back and
knock the [__] out of him or do whatever
the [__] it is i'm gonna do that
and i remember when i came back here in
i drove by the bar where he used to hung
out and i thought it was time to go in
there and [__] him up a little bit
for what he had done but
he didn't do anything it was me who did
it to myself by not [__]
i was a good player but i wasn't the
best player
i wasn't a good defensive player i would
always let you pass me and tried to
steal the ball from you
on the side yeah yada yada whatever the
[__] [__] was
it ate away at me for years then my
mother's death happened and then
that quitting basketball [__] ate away
at me
and there was only one [__]
redemption
and that redemption came on july 16th
1991. that was the day i got on stage
that was the only chance i had of
redeeming myself so all those years
well i thought the pain of me getting
high was about my mother
and it was about my father and it was
about the situation
and i was blaming the world for all my
problems and i was [__] uh not taking
responsibility for my actions
and in my world it was always somebody
else's fault and that situation was
ridden's fault
and because of that he's gonna die or
i'm gonna hit him with a stick or
i'm gonna get people to hit him all
these reasons why
no they all came to me when i walked off
that stage
july 16 1991
but if i was going to do this i i was
going to commit to it
the same way i was going to commit to
the way i did basketball
but this time i wasn't going to let
nobody control my fate
there weren't gonna be no [__]
coaches [__] i was gonna be the [__]
coach i was gonna be the commander
the captain kirk of the enterprise and
this is why
this happened this comedy i got enough
time to think about this
and this kid hit me this weekend was the
final piece
in that puzzle you know i've had a lot a
lot of time to reflect on [__] here
you know i know what comics are going
through right now a lot of comics are
having a hard time
not financially they're having a hard
time
what their life used to be and what
their life was
me when i kissed that [__] comedy
store goodbye
uh in august i knew it was probably the
last time i would see the building
am i saying that close no no i'm not
saying anything like that what i'm
saying is
i kissed that whole part of my life
goodbye
but i take it back
to the lesson i learned when i was 13
and 14 about quitting something you
don't quit something
because somebody puts a lid on you you
quit when it's your [__] turn to quit
when it's your time to quit
when you're content with the job that
you've done that's when you [__] quit
i quit time i quit basketball because oh
the pieces didn't go my
[__] joey's way so he's gonna [__] out
as usual
and [__] quit thank god i didn't have
the same
pussiness when i got in the [__]
comedy i don't know what made me tell
you guys the story today but i feel that
people and
you know in weird places the holidays
are here
it's going to make you think about your
future and it's going to make you think
about what things you want to do you're
looking at the job you have now
and you're seeing how secure it is do i
have a future doing this
am i going to be replaced is covered
going to keep campaigning my bill this
is all things you got to think about
and this is what i thought about in this
whole thing was
what helped me what made me
the comic i was today or
what i'm doing today what what's still
keeping me relevant
wasn't the funniness and all this [__]
it was the lesson i learned about
quitting
as a 15 year old you never quit nothing
especially when you have that much
passion for something you never quit
nothing you never let get
something get it get in the way between
you
and your [__] dream and what your
mission is [__] that [__]
i just want to let you know because i i
know a lot of people are having
hard times now and sometimes listen
i could probably afford a psychiatrist
but i'm not going to go see a
psychiatrist
right now these next few months it's not
going to be about
this or that it's going to be about your
mental health
it's going to be about your mental
health trust me another lockdown in
california
another lockdown across the country no
ppl loans
people are still trying to get
unemployment
blah blah blah blah blah you've still
got to push forward every day
and most importantly is you can't quit
you can't quit at any level it's not
your shoulder
makes you quit it's not your need you
know for me
i told everybody i quit basketball
because i had that lung
infection and i couldn't run anymore i
didn't quit because no [__] lung
infection
i quit because i was a [__] [__] and
i let something hold me down
don't ever ever ever ever in this life
let something hold you the [__] down you
understand me
you push forward i'm happy so much today
that i got to tell you that story
because it was on my chest for a long
time
and i had finally put that one piece
together the element that was missing
which was me quitting basketball that
stayed with me for the rest of my
[__] life
that's why i attacked comedy as hard as
i [__] did
by me because of me quitting basketball
never quit dick look at it analyze it
realize it see
you know for me i'm five foot eleven
what were my chances of making in the
nba
but that wasn't for me to decide that
wasn't for me to decide
my decision was to keep pushing
until they tell me no and even then
even then even then i was just watching
a football game maybe
thanksgiving somewhere where they were
talking about a guy
he got drafted he got hurt he was
loading shelves in the supermarket and
somebody gave him a [__] shot
yeah somebody will give you a shot but
you gotta earn that shot
it's not like somebody's gonna walk into
a bar and go oh you're the most handsome
guy i've ever seen
i'm gonna put you in my next hollywood
[__] thriller
i wish it happened that way but it
[__] doesn't
but the lesson from today monday
november 30th
is don't quit don't [__] quit nothing
keep going and if you do quit it's going
to live with you forever that
that quitting at the age of 14
that earthed at me for 14 [__] years
until i got on stage can you imagine
getting eaten away at something
i knew a lot of things were eating away
at me my mother's dead
you know me being a dumb [__] the drugs
but it all started by me [__]
quitting basketball
that's what really started it wasn't my
mother's dad
it wasn't i could tell you a bunch of
[__] lies it was none of that
it was for me quitting that it was
against my beliefs
it's against who the [__] i am
it'll be the way i hear for the rest of
your [__] life
if there's something you want to go back
to or something
you know you get wives i don't want you
to be in a band no more you get
you know people tell you your art
whatever
come to all go [__] themselves i want
you to play your hand i want you to do
what you put on this planet to [__]
do
you know if you want to train monkeys
but there's no money in it your wife
makes you keep your i.t job
tell them to suck your dick you want to
go train [__] monkeys
because that's what you would put on
this [__] planet to do and with that
i leave you don't forget tonight
6 p.m eastern time 3 o'clock
in california 2 o'clock in [__]
colorado
ozzie's bone yard sirixxm
channel 38 number two i want to thank
you guys all for supporting me on
patreon
you guys are phenomenal we got another
video coming up this week the album of
the week
and we also got a little uh reefer
product review coming at you you know
what i'm saying
a couple little podcasts i take care of
you over there we have a good time
over there on patreon but if not just
stay here with me and uncle joey
i'm starting to get my [__] uh
voice back i'm starting to get my mind
back
everything is working all at once the
alpha brain the cbd lion
everything's working all at once and i
just want to let you guys know
it's going to be another [__]
great week except
you are here so without further ado
thank you very much
i love you guys and i'll see you
wednesday morning
tip top magoo ready to go now for a word
from our sponsors
this week says draftkings don't forget
tonight
the paul a you got you got the [__]
total and the under
and you're gonna take that and roll it
into the [__] tuesday night
baltimore raven pittsburgh steeler game
and as far as cbd lying they're always
there for you
now i'm gonna pass that you on you're
gonna get the links
you're gonna go smoke a joint and you're
gonna go take care of whatever monday
has to offer you [__]
i love you stay black thank you for
coming uncle joey's joint again
and for giving me another opportunity to
come into your living rooms
love you but before we go like i said in
the beginning
this is brought to you from the heart of
new jersey just like my main
people draftkings they're right here in
the heart
of [__] jersey and this is the season
to give
and give big and make and make as much
money as you can
without [__] doing unemployment
paperwork i'm gonna try to make you a
little bit of [__] money here
the old-fashioned way we're gonna hit
the book that's it
how do we hit the book it starts tonight
it starts tonight with seattle
minus five and a half against the
philadelphia eagles of overnight is 49.
we're gonna make a little money tonight
maybe on the total look at the total
okay
and then tomorrow we're gonna we got
baltimore at pittsburgh this is the
coveted game that they're picking up
from last week
no big deal these coveted games they
paid just as well as anybody else
kickoff is 8 pm uh tomorrow night
this is where we're going to [__]
kill them all right while everybody else
is sleeping off
you're going to get a chance to double
your money when either team scores a
touchdown
are you [__] crazy you think you're
dreaming no you heard me right
one single [__] touchdown boom you
made it you made little guitars for
yourself
all you got to do is sign up at the
promotions at draftkings and use code
joey
and wait for the ball to cross the
[__] touchdown zone that's it you
jump up and down with your little asian
friends
whatever the [__] you want to do
download the draftking sportsbook app
now
right now because draftkings is giving
all new users a chance
to earn up to a sign up bonus of a
thousand dollars
who's giving you dick on on [__]
november 30th nobody
uncle joey's giving you a thousand
dollars when you go to draftkings that's
how you
get the party started then you're gonna
download the draft cook's
uh app and start making it [__] rain
okay when i make it rain
i don't want you to meet up got bones i
want you to make a little
little money every night 200 150 go for
180 start small
build your [__] bankroll but tonight
forget about it seattle
you got the total you got the under
whatever the [__] you want you got
and you got a thousand dollars to start
the party with all right
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now
use promo code [__] joey and when you
sign up you get this can't miss
offer double your money if either
pittsburgh
or baltimore sport touchdown tuesday
night's game tomorrow night's game all
right that's
it that's right there it takes one
[__] touchdown
and you double your gears when you use
promo code
joey during the sign up for a limited
time only
from the heart of new jersey right here
at the draftking sports book
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say you got to be 21 or older
new jersey indiana or pennsylvania only
there's some other states being added go
check and see
tennessee colorado whatever deposit
bonus requires a 25 times playthrough
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
book for details now if you got a
gambling problem
there's help you call 1-800 gambler and
if you're in indianapolis or indiana i'm
sorry
call 1-809 women but if you want to get
this [__] party started
right now download the strat king
sportsbook app
use promo code joey we're gonna get the
party started right tonight with seattle
philadelphia over and under 49 and then
we're gonna roll it in
to the draftking special on tuesday
night who's better than you
nobody draft kings code
use joey j-o-e-y and let's get this
[__] holiday season started
the uncle joey's joint is also brought
to you by
the best c b d lion
they're not [__] around this ain't
some cbd company that's just opening up
and putting eye drops in there and
you're jumping up and down with your
white friends
i feel so much better no you know you're
just being joe jerk off as usual
if you're gonna work with cbd go with
the best cbdlion.com right now
roll on kinesiology tape vapors milk
chocolate dark
chocolate gummy bears bath balls
jesus christ next summer they're gonna
have a cbd firecracker you pull up your
ass
and you just keep hopping up and down
the [__] street go to cbdlion.com
right now
we're not [__] around we're gonna
give you 10 20
off when you use code joey church
whatever the [__] you use
it's better than the [__] you're buying
down the corner from some guy named hugo
at the [__]
dire store you [__] go to
cbdlion.com right now
pressing code joey church and get 20
off delivered to your [__] crib
that's it and that's that it's cbd line
in my world
what there is a tape whether if you want
to eat a piece of chocolate
you want to smoke a vapor you rub the
cbd line
roll out of your nut sack whatever the
[__] you need to do to make the party
started
cbd line will get that party started for
you go to cbdline.com right now
press enjoy your church and get the
party started
have a great [__] day i love you
[__] silk filthy animals
i'll see you wednesday morning tip top
magoo i don't want to hear no [__]
stories i love you
forget the blow off the camera like it's
my [__] 80th birthday and [__]
got the mention
you